Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, Ausgabe Nummer 27 und auch die dritte und letzte Ausgabe vom Linux-Tag 2006 in Wiesbaden. Ein weiteres Gespräch steht vor uns und zu Gast ist Henrik Heigl. Hallo Henrik. Du bist bei dem Projekt CACert aktiv, bist dort Pressesprecher, Public Relations, was ist da der offizielle Titel?
Eigentlich Pressesprecher und Assure, das macht man also so in einem mit.
Und wir haben schon einen der Fachbegriffe vorausgegriffen, den wir jetzt erklären wollen, aber bevor wir da in die Tiefe gehen, sollte man vielleicht erst noch mal ein bisschen beleuchten, wozu das CACert-Projekt gegründet wurde. Ich hatte das ja vor einiger Zeit im Chaosradio Express auch schon selber schon mal angerissen, aber da gibt es auch noch einiges, was man noch weiter hinterfragen könnte und auch sollte. Deswegen hatte ich dich gefragt, hier noch mal zu dem Interview bereit zu stehen. Kannst du mal kurz anreißen, was ist CACert, wo kommt das Projekt her, wann ist es gegründet worden und worum geht es?
Ja, das Projekt, wie gesagt, entstand ungefähr im Jahr 2000 aus Australien. Dann wurde 2002 die ING daraus gegründet, mit dem Ziel, digitale Zertifikate, digitale Signaturen einfach der Allgemeinheit nahe zu bringen, um ein größeres Sicherheitsbewusstsein den Leuten einfach nahe zu legen.
Genau, also bei den Zertifikaten geht es dann primär um verschlüsselte Kommunikation im Web, also nicht ausschließlich, aber primär. Also wenn ich eine Webseite ansurfe und ich möchte gerne nutzerspezifische Daten eingeben, Homebanking, kaufen, Amazon, hier, eBay, da, überall da, wo man halt so privatsfern kritische Dinge eingibt, an der Stelle wird ja HTTPS wichtig und das Zertifikat stellt sicher, dass man weiß, um wen es sich handelt. Also einerseits geht es um Verschlüsselung, aber andererseits geht es eben auch um die Identifizierung und darum kümmert sich ja CACert, richtig?
Genau, praktisch um die digitale Signatur entsprechend zu einem normalen Unterschriftsvorgang unter einem Brief oder einem Vertrag oder einem ähnlichen Dokument, was man so, ich sage jetzt mal aus den analogen Zeiten her kennt, das ist das praktisch in digitaler Form. Praktisch ein sogenanntes SSL-Zertifikat auf einem Web-Server würde dann von CACert entsprechend ausgestellt und beglaubigt werden.
Und wo wird jetzt CACert für mich interessant, also wo berührt mich das jetzt als Privatperson?
Als Privatperson ist eigentlich so das Einsatzgebiet, dass man sagt, ich möchte zum Beispiel eine E-Mail schreiben. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mit Tim eine E-Mail schreibe, dann kann sich im ersten Moment eigentlich heutzutage gar nicht mehr sicher sein, dass ich eigentlich auch der Henrik Heigl bin. Das kann auch irgendjemand anders gewesen sein, der sich als mich ausgibt. Und dann Tim zum Beispiel sagt, du ich habe hier ein tolles Produkt, kauf das mal. Also die typischen Anwendungsfälle, Spams und Virenweiterverbreitung und was es da nicht noch alles gibt. Und an der Stelle wäre dann der Punkt, wenn man genau wie den Brief, den man unterschrieben hat, wenn man dann die E-Mail digital unterschrieben hat, dass sich der Empfänger sicher sein kann. In dem Fall, wenn er das Zertifikat aufruft und die Daten entsprechend überprüft hat, dass der Name natürlich stimmt, dass auch wirklich die Person, die das abgeschickt hat, das auch wirklich war.
Okay, jetzt kommt ja noch ein zweiter Aspekt rein, den ich jetzt so noch gar nicht erwähnt hatte, nämlich, dass man eben diese Verschlüsselung, also diese Zertifikatsstruktur auch zum Verschlüsseln von E-Mails verwenden kann. Üblicherweise, wenn man jetzt von E-Mail-Verschlüsselung redet, denkt man ja mal als erstes an PGP bzw. Wie verhält sich jetzt diese S-MIME-Struktur dazu?
Richtig. Also da ist S-MIME ein ganz klein wenig anders, weil es im ersten Schritt bzw. primär nicht zum Verschlüsseln verwendet wird, sondern, wie ich eben gerade schon sagte, eher zum digitalen Unterschreiben von E-Mails. Das heißt, die E-Mail kommt eigentlich, wenn ich es nicht noch zusätzlich verschlüsseln, erstmal ganz normal an. Das heißt, der Endanwender kann die auch lesen, im Gegensatz vielleicht zu PGP-verschlüsselten Geschichten bzw. signierten Geschichten, wo unten drunter meistens irgendeinen Text mit irgendwelchen hieroglyphischen Zeichen steht. So ein S-MIME-Zertifikat, was unten drunter hängt, ist auch eine Datei, die aber von den meisten E-Mail-Clients plattformunabhängig sofort erkannt wird und auch dargestellt wird. Das ist also der Endanwender, der es in einer schön darstellbaren Form auch einfach angezeigt bekommt.
Und inwiefern unterscheidet sich das technisch von PGP?
Ja, dass es halt meistens in den Browsern eingebunden ist. Der Standard ist natürlich der S-MIME-Standard, das sind da die X509-Zertifikate. Das heißt also, jedes Programm, das mit dem Standard X509 umgehen kann, sei es jetzt wie gesagt ein E-Mail-Programm, aber es geht zum Beispiel auch das Signieren von Dokumenten, zum Beispiel Adobe PDF bietet das an, das wäre dann wieder die kommerzielle Variante oder auch Open Office, dann kann ich dann auch Dokumente damit entsprechend signieren und auch digital unterschreiben.
Also CACert ist all about Authentication, das heißt das Projekt ist jetzt angetreten um den Privatanwendern, aber eben auch Firmen die Möglichkeit zu geben, sich im Prinzip kostenlos an dieser Authentifizierungsstruktur im Internet teilzunehmen, weil bisher ist es ja so, wenn ich so ein Zertifikat haben will, dann kann man das natürlich auch haben, aber nur gegen Geld, dann muss man zu Veri-Sign oder anderen großen Unternehmen gehen, die CAC Center Saudi macht das ja dann auch, zwar für E-Mails immer noch kostenlos, aber für die Web-Server-Zertifikate muss man ja auch ein bisschen was bezahlen. Genau, und das auch nicht nur einmal, sondern auch regelmäßig und das skaliert auch glaube ich nach oben ganz gut im Preis.
Ja, die Preise weiß ich jetzt auch nicht auswendig, aber für den Privatanwender ist es natürlich uninteressant.
Genau. Und kannst du mal beschreiben, wie jetzt da eure Vorgehensweise ist? Also wie muss man auf euch zukommen, um jetzt so ein kostenloses Zertifikat zu bekommen?
Ja, der Endanwender oder auch, da kommen wir später denke ich mal noch drauf, Vereine oder entsprechende Firmen. Wir gehen jetzt erstmal von Privatpersonen aus, die kommt dann zu uns bzw. auf die Webseite www.cacert.org. Dann gibt es rechts einen entsprechenden Punkt Join, dass man also dem Ganzen, ja ich sag mal beitreten kann bzw. daran teilhaben kann. Dann legt die Person sich einen Account an, kann zu dem Zeitpunkt allerdings schon ein Certifikat, ein E-Mail-Zertifikat ausstellen, das im ersten Schritt allerdings noch nicht beglaubigt ist, d.h. es noch namenlos ist. Dann ist der nächste Schritt, dass sich die Person natürlich auch irgendwo ausweisen müsste bzw. durch andere Leute einfach beglaubigt wird, dass die Person auch wirklich diejenige ist, die sie ist, d.h. in deinem Fall jetzt Tim Pritlove, in meinem Fall Henrik Heigl. Das funktioniert nach einem Punktesystem, d.h. die sogenannten Assurer vergeben dann entsprechende Punkte. Also Assurer sind die Leute, die jetzt die Beglaubigung durchführen, auf Deutsch Beglaubigung, auf Englisch Assurans, das ist ein bisschen komisch übersetzt, müsste aber so ungefähr passen und Minimum sind zwei andere Personen, die einem dann die Identität beglaubigen. Dann kann die Person diese E-Mail-Zertifikate sich nochmal ausstellen und dann ist der Name in dem Zertifikat enthalten. der Name wird auch angezeigt, wenn man sich die Zertifikate anschaut als Empfänger und die sind dann entsprechend beglaubigt.
Dazu muss man in Real-World-Kontakt treten, also man muss die Personen live in echt treffen.
diese Assurance funktioniert wirklich nach dem Vier-Augen-Prinzip. Man sitzt sich gegenüber, also auf Messen oder Veranstaltungen. Oder es gibt auch die Möglichkeit bei cacert.org, wenn man sich angemeldet hat, einen Assure zu finden. Dann kann man sich den innerhalb eines Kilometerradios von 10 bis 100 Kilometern aussuchen.
ich gebe meine Postleitzahl ein und dann sagt er, da sitzt einer rum?
Nach den Orten. Noch ist es nicht nach den Postleitzahlen gestaffelt. Man gibt den Ort ein und sucht in der Datenbank, wen gibt es ungefähr in dem Umkreis. Man spuckt dann eine Liste aus, die kann man dann entsprechend anschreiben und kontaktieren. Dann soll man sich dann bei einem melden und dann kann man einen Kontakt ausmachen, wo man sich dann treffen möchte, um das durchzuführen. Das funktioniert dann, wie hier z.B. auf der Messe, ganz normal, dass man ein kleines Formular hat, auf dem man seinen Namen, Geburtstag und die E-Mail-Adresse angibt. Die E-Mail-Adresse ist auch gleichzeitig der Account-Name und anhand dessen und zusätzlich den Ausweisdokumenten, nämlich zwei, einen Lichtbildausweis, ein amtliches wie z.B. ein Reisepass oder ein normaler Personalausweis und ein zweites Dokument, was im Zweifelsfall auch eine Kreditkarte sein kann, die unterschrieben ist, womit man dann einfach die Unterschrift auf dem Formular überprüfen kann. Wenn das zwei Personen einen glauben, dass er wirklich die Person ist, dann hat man eine entsprechende Punktzahl zusammen.
Aber so eine Unterschrift auf einer Kreditkarte ist ja kein offizieller Vorgang. Ich kriege eine Kreditkarte zugeschickt und dann unterschreibe ich selber, wo er das zuschaut.
Richtig, das ist aber nur, um die Unterschrift entsprechend zu erkennen. Wenn der natürlich die Kreditkarte noch gar nicht unterschrieben hat, was wir auch schon hatten, und der wollte die dann am Stand unterschreiben und wir so, ja, ne, das nicht. Also schon so, dass das vorher alles unterschrieben ist. Die Unterschrift auf dem Formular wird also auch am Stand selber durchgeführt. Das heißt also vorher vorgefertigte Formulare inklusive Unterschrift nehmen wir nicht an. Da müssen die Leute dann noch mal im Beisein des Assurers auch unterschreiben. Das heißt also oben steht auch dann so ein kleiner Passus auf dem Zettel drauf, auf dem Formular drauf, dass die Angaben alle wahrheitsgemäß sind.
Okay, das heißt ich habe mir jetzt, um es noch mal so zusammenzufassen, als erstes marschiere ich zu der Webseite, dann mache ich mir einen Login. Und als nächstes muss ich dann aber irgendwie erstmal jemanden in real life treffen. Also das heißt ich kümmere mich in irgendeiner Form entweder auf einer Messe oder eben durch Privatkontakt, dass ich zu so einem Assurer hingehe. Dann sage ich ihm hier sind meine Dokumente, da steht drauf, dass ich ich bin. Und dann habe ich welchen Status, dann bin ich erstmal was, dann bin ich erstmal so einmal erstmal zur Kenntnis genommen worden.
Dann ist man zur Kenntnis genommen und so genannt Assured. Und der Name steht dann in den Zertifikaten drinne.
Und was kann ich dann mit diesem Zertifikat, kann ich mir dann mehrere Zertifikate bereits geben lassen, für meine Webserver zum Beispiel oder ist das jetzt nur für E-Mail?
Im ersten Schritt, wenn das nur zwei Personen gemacht haben, wobei man davon ausgeht, dass die die maximale Punktzahl ausgeben dürfen, ist im ersten Schritt E-Mail-Zertifikate. Wenn man Webserver-Zertifikate ausgeben möchte, braucht man die nächste Stufe, das wären dann 100 Punkte, wobei dann halt Minimum drei Assurer notwendig sind, die einem dann, wenn sie jeweils 35 Punkte, also das Maximum an Punkten vergeben dürfen, halt dann diese typischen 105 Punkte hat.
Das heißt, man bekommt mehr Punkte, indem man sich einfach mehr Leuten gegenüber auf dieselbe Art und Weise ausweist. Das ist jetzt nicht noch eine andere Stufe, wo ich noch mit meiner Geburtsurkunde anrücken muss, sondern es geht einfach nur um die Zahl der Leute, um abzusichern, dass da mögliche Fehler, ganz genau, sozusagen nicht sich wiederholen. Okay.
Also Fehler sollten sich sowieso nicht wiederholen, weil man das ja dann kontrolliert, eben in diesem Vier-Augen-Prinzip, aber dass das halt ein etwas größeres Vertrauensverhältnis einfach darstellt.
Okay, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich den notwendigen Punktestand habe, kann ich mir dann direkt in der Webseite auch Zertifikate erzeugen lassen. Und die bekomme ich dann, und die sind dann eben für meine Domänen, die ich dann vorher wahrscheinlich noch angeben muss, natürlich, weil es steht ja in dem Zertifikat drin. Und das ist dann so ein digitales Dokument, was von dem sogenannten RUT-Zertifikat von der CACert unterschrieben ist. Das heißt, das Hauptdokument, dieser Haupt-Krypto-Schlüssel von der CACert-Gemeinde hat jetzt gesagt, dass das wahr ist und dass halt andere das machen. Aber ein Problem ist natürlich dabei, dass wenn ich jetzt in meinem, wenn dann jemand anders in seinem Web-Brause diese Webseite ansurfte und das eben über HTTPS macht, dann bekommt er zwar dieses Zertifikat übermittelt, aber dann kennt er ja CACert nicht.
In neueren Browsern, in einigen, muss man dazu sagen, ist dieses Zertifikat ja schon drin. Ich sage das mit Vorsicht, weil das immer auf die Leute bzw. auf die Distributeuren ankommt, auf die Entwickler ankommt, wie weit die da schon gesagt haben, okay, wir binden dieses RUT-Zertifikat, das RUT-CR schon mit ein.
Also bei Linux-Distribution jetzt zum Beispiel, meinst du?
Ja, genau, in dem Fall jetzt Linux-Distribution. Ich habe vorhin gehört, dass das im Conqueror schon drinnen sein soll. Ich habe es selber noch nicht ausprobiert, aber es gibt wohl schon auch einige Distributionen, die das in diese Paketausschüttung mit reingebaut haben. Und das geht also voran in dem Sinne. Da es ja ein freiwilliges Projekt ist, was natürlich sich auch durch Spenden mehr oder weniger finanziert, sind wir natürlich auch weiterhin auf solche Donations und Spenden angewiesen. Aber das geht voran, dass das dann irgendwann komplett eingebaut ist.
Mein Eindruck bei dem Projekt ist ja, dass der Goodwill da sehr verbreitet ist. Also wenn man sich den CACert-Stand hier anschaut, und ich habe bisher eigentlich auf keiner Veranstaltung andere Erfahrungen gemacht, da ist also immer im Sieges treiben. Also die Leute tun mir fast leid. Ich glaube, keiner hat so viel zu tun, wie diese Eschurer, die da sitzen.
Ich glaube, wir sind der einzige Stand, der eine riesenlange Schlange hat. Und wir müssen uns so fast schon den Magen ziehen.
Okay, also halt noch mal fest. Man muss sich registrieren, man muss sich so weit eschuren lassen, dass man bestimmten Punktelevel erreicht hat. Wie weit geht das mit diesen Punkten? Was für Karrieren kann man da sozusagen noch erstreben? Wird man dann automatisch irgendwann Eschurer oder ist das dann nochmal was anderes?
Das ist dann sozusagen die nächste Stufe. Also das Maximum, was man selber von anderen vergeben bekommen kann, sind halt die 100 Punkte. Dann ist man voll Eschuert und hat gleichzeitig sozusagen auch die nächste Stufe erreicht, dass man selber Eschurer ist. Das heißt, man könnte ab diesem Zeitpunkt oder man ist natürlich auch gewünscht, dass man das tut. Ab diesem Zeitpunkt kann man dann selber andere Leuten ihre Identität beglaubigen.
Ich habe jetzt gerade mal bei mir geguckt und ich stelle fest, ich habe 120 Punkte.
Ja, das heißt, in dem Fall wirst du wahrscheinlich entweder schon einige Leute selber auch erschürt haben. Das kann sein.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Es kann allerdings auch sein, dass auf Messen gab es mal die Möglichkeit, vor einiger Zeit, du hast ja glaube ich das Zertifikat auch schon ein bisschen länger, den Erkampf ein bisschen länger, dass die Leute teilweise auch mehr Punkte vergeben können. Also es gibt dann, um in einem Bereich, in dem es noch keine Assure in dem Sinne gibt oder überhaupt die Präsenz von CACert, gibt es dann die Möglichkeit, temporär sogenannte Super-Assure zu ernennen. Das wird dann von der Organisation entschieden, die dann erst mal diese Assure auch ein bisschen pushen können, ein bisschen streuen können, damit dort ein bisschen höhere Flächendeckung stattfindet. Aber in Deutschland ist das, denke ich mal, sind wir mittlerweile recht flächendeckend.
Wie viele Assure würdest du schätzen? Gibt es so?
Im Moment gibt es weltweit über 5.800 Assure. Die zwei letzten Ziffern kann ich jetzt nicht auswendig sagen, weil die sich tagtäglich ändern.
Und so in Deutschland denn etwa?
Ist nicht genau bekannt, aus der Datenbank auch nicht auslesbar. Das wären dann ja wieder so Datenschutzgeschichten. Aber ich persönlich schätze, nachdem ich seit jetzt mittlerweile fast zwei Jahren selber aktiv auf Messen bin und dort auch Assura produziert habe, würde ich persönlich einfach mal nur schätzen, dass das auf alle Fälle über 1000, 1500, wenn nicht sogar 2000 sind. Aber das ist wirklich eine ganz vage Zahl.
Aber auf jeden Fall ein signifikanter Anteil auch des Projektes.
Also Deutschland hat hier einen sehr, sehr hohen Anteil auch an Präsenz, an Bekanntheitsgrad und so weiter und so fort. Andere Länder auch, keine Frage. Aber Deutschland ist da, denke ich, mal der Vorreiter.
Ja, merkt man ja auch, also Linux an sich erfreut sich größter Popularität schon seit eh und je. Und generell natürlich auch Open Source, das merkt man hier auch auf dem Linux-Tag, allein durch die Zahl der Projekte, die Zahl der Firmen vor allem, die auch in dem Bereich operieren. Und natürlich auch vor allem durch eben so freie Projekte, wo eben Leute sagen, okay, bei der Sache mache ich mit, das ist prima, das bringt uns halt insgesamt weiter. Ja, jetzt ist es ja auch möglich, als Firma von CACert zu profitieren, wo es ja bestlang eigentlich immer nur den Weg gab, dass man eben über den kommerziellen Anbieter geht. Gibt es da irgendwelche Einschränkungen, also gibt es irgendwelche Firmen oder sagen wir mal allgemein Organisationen, die daran nicht teilhaben können oder ist das generell offen?
Da im Moment würde mir nichts einfallen, was dagegen sprechen würde. Es muss halt eine, wie es so schön heißt, ausweisbare Firma in dem Sinne sein, eine Organisation, ein eingetragener gemeinnütziger Verein etc. Da gibt es bei uns dann wieder intern einen sogenannten Organisations-Assure, der das dann mit der entsprechenden Organisation oder der Firma durchgeht, was dann im Einzelnen gebraucht wird, also welche Unterlagen gebraucht werden, weil der Ablauf ist grundsätzlich derselbe wie bei der Privatperson. Allerdings werden hier einige Unterlagen mehr von der Firma natürlich gebraucht, das heißt, nicht jeder kann ja sagen, er ist einfach Geschäftsführer von irgendeiner Firma, und am Ende stimmt das nicht, das muss also auch notariell beglaubigt werden. Und einige andere Punkte halt einfach und da ist der Organisations-Assure zuständig, der das dann mit den Leuten entsprechend durchgeht, mit den Firmen und Organisationen.
Und ist man jetzt, ist jetzt ein Organisations-Assure, inwiefern unterscheidet der sich jetzt von einem normalen Assurer, was ist da anders?
Der hat eine entsprechende, ich sag jetzt mal, rechtliche Ausbildung, das heißt, es ist ein Rechtsberater oder ein Rechtsanwalt oder etwas ähnliches, damit man sich da so schon einen gewissen Standard einfach...
Okay, also das wendet sich quasi nach wie vor ein Freiwilliger, aber die, die ohnehin in ihrem Beruf schon notar sind oder was auch immer.
Richtig, also die müssen schon eine entsprechende rechtliche Ausbildung in dem Sinne haben.
Ahja, was kommt da in Frage? Also Rechtsanwalt, notar ist klar? Rechtsanwalt, notar, genau. Sonst noch was, Rechtspfleger gibt es doch glaube ich auch noch so, sowas, ne?
Ja genau, die dürfen das glaube ich auch, ja.
Okay, so das heißt dann kann ich einfach jetzt, denk mal vor allem für Zuhörer von Chaosradio betreffend das natürlich vor allem auch Vereine, so wenn ich jetzt allein schon an CCC denke, also die ganzen regionalen Vereine, die natürlich dann im Prinzip auch das benötigen, auch ccc.de ist ja vor kurzem auf den CACert ausgewichen.
Wo uns dann natürlich gleich an der Stelle natürlich auch mal offiziell bedanken können dafür, dass CCC natürlich jetzt auch CACert einsetzt, ist natürlich auch schon eine ganze Masse, die dann jetzt praktisch kommt.
Hat das irgendwas ausgelöst, dass wir das gemacht haben?
Nein, das haben wir nicht weiter.
Okay, dann wollen wir mal was jetzt, die Sendung da auslöst. Aber auf jeden Fall war das auch ein relativ problemloser Prozess. Man muss dazu sagen, dass natürlich im Club auch viele Schura mit drin sind. Also als die Diskussion aufkam, haben sich gleich mehrere Leute auf den Mailing-Listen gemeldet und gesagt, ja hier alles kein Problem. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war mir das noch nicht so klar, dass es jetzt für Organisationen auch so einfach zu machen ist. Aber lange Rede kurzer Sinn, es ist halt möglich auch für Vereine und andere Gruppen einfach hinzugehen und zu sagen, hier wir sind eine anerkanntere rechtliche Entität, jetzt möchten wir gerne das Zertifikat haben. Und das macht die Sache natürlich auch schon einfacher. Allein schon deshalb, weil natürlich auch so das Betreiben, man könnte ja auch hergehen und so haben wir es ja auch vorher gemacht, dass man eben seine eigene technische Zertifikatsinstallation sozusagen aufruft und sagt, ich benutze jetzt einfach hier die verfügbare Software, in dem Fall ist das ja OpenSSL, mit der man diese ganzen Zertifikate erzeugen kann. Aber abgesehen davon, dass man natürlich dann auch erstmal sein eigenes Rout-Zertifikat in die Welt bringen muss, bevor andere Leute das akzeptieren, hat man natürlich auch diesen ganzen Hessel mit privaten Key beschützen und wer macht das und gerade freiwilligen Projekten, ist das ja immer so eine Sache.
Ja und wenn man natürlich selber sein eigenes Rout-Zertifikat in dem Sinne ausgibt, dann muss ja die Gegenpartei in dem Sinne dem ja auch wieder glauben und wenn es da keine richtige CA gibt, die dahinter steht, ist das immer so ein bisschen schwierig auch den Leuten auch klar zu machen. Ja, ja, du darfst denen auch glauben, das ist halt auch alles in Ordnung.
Wie sieht so die Zukunft aus beim CACert-Projekt? Ich denke, im Wesentlichen konzentriert sich erstmal alles darauf, dass man einerseits natürlich so viele Leute gewinnt wie möglich, um daran teilzunehmen, aber eben auch dafür zu sorgen, dass dieses Rout-Zertifikat in möglichst viele Systeme kommt. Gibt es da irgendwie politische Aktivitäten, um jetzt Mozilla oder ähnliche Projekte dazu zu bringen, das zum Beispiel in Firefox zu integrieren?
Ja, wie gesagt, das Projekt in dem Sinne läuft. Da sind wir also auch immer froh, wenn da noch der eine oder andere dazustoßen möchte, um da auch politisch und intern entsprechend tätig zu werden. Die sollen sich dann einfach bei CACert melden, bzw. auch bei mir können sie sich melden. Ich leite das dann entsprechend weiter. Wenn da Interesse besteht, auf alle Fälle. Immer sehr gerne gesehen.
Und gibt es da jetzt schon Berührungen mit dem Mozilla-Projekt zum Beispiel, um dem Firefox das CACert, also das RUT-Zertifikat, unterzuschieben? Weil das wäre ja sozusagen die Voraussetzung dafür. Für die Leute, die das jetzt noch nicht so verstanden haben, das Problem ist ja, wenn ich auf so eine Webseite komme und man bekommt ein Zertifikat, wo drauf steht CACert, hat gesagt, das ist okay, aber der Browser kennt halt CACert nicht, dann gibt es halt erst mal Fehlermeldungen und Fehlermeldungen sind immer so eine Sache. Nicht, dass die Leute jetzt besonders viel Misstrauen aufbringen heutzutage im Internet, aber angemessen wäre es halt schon, aber das möchte man natürlich verhindern. Man möchte gerne einfach da so draufklicken und es funktioniert. Gibt es da jetzt schon erste Schritte, um das zu...
Erste Schritte auf alle Fälle. Die Gespräche mit Netscape, Mozilla und diesen, ich sage jetzt mal freien oder gängigen Browsern, sind alle aufgenommen worden. Ein entsprechendes Audit findet auch statt, dass man sich auch gegenüber von Firmen natürlich entsprechend auch ausweisen kann. Man braucht dann immer so ein Zettelchen, wo dann drauf steht, ja, das ist auch alles in Ordnung, weil sonst könnte ja eigentlich jeder herkommen und sagen, er ist eine CA und er macht das und er hat halb 5.000 Mitglieder, aber es muss ja auch entsprechend alles sicher gesichert werden.
Also Audit heißt, dass jetzt sozusagen extern die interne Struktur, die Organisationsstruktur von CACert analysiert wird.
Richtig, genau.
Und das findet gerade statt.
Das ist sozusagen jetzt gerade in der Mache, das findet die ganze Zeit schon statt.
Und wo ist der geheime Schlüssel von dem RU-Zertifikat? In welchem Tresor lagert der?
Der wird in irgendeinem australischen Tresor lagern, wo dort der Sitze ist.
Und der ist da ganz sicher?
Der ist da sicher.
Weiß man, in welcher Stadt der sich befindet?
Man weiß mit Sicherheit, in welcher Stadt der sich befindet, aber das ist bekannt.
Okay, aber der wird auf jeden Fall ordentlich gehütet. Okay, das möchte man ja hoffen. Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal ein paar Verweise ins Internet geben. Also die Homepage von CACert ist cacert.org. Es gibt auch einen Wiki unter wiki.cazert.org für viele Fragen. Und es gibt auch einen Blog für aktuelle News. Da passiert das eine oder andere. Und wenn ihr Lust habt, selber auch eure Dienste über HTTPS anzubieten im Web oder eben auch S-Mime für die Verschlüsselung zu verwenden, dann könnt ihr halt dort euch selber einen Account machen und bei Fragen natürlich auch in den Kontakt treten mit den Leuten. Und vielleicht habt ihr auch Lust, als Ashura da tätig zu werden in den einzelnen Regionen, wo es vielleicht noch eine Lücke gibt.
Es gibt mit Sicherheit noch weiße Flecken.
Ich denke, es kann auch nicht schaden, so viele Leute zu haben wie möglich. Dann wisst ihr jetzt, wo ihr hingehen müsst. Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen? Ah ja, wir haben was vergessen. Du hast nämlich vorhin noch erwähnt, dass man die Zertifikate auch zum Code-Signing verwenden kann.
Ja, also man kann auch seinen Code in dem Sinne, genauso wie man Dokumente unterschreiben kann, kann man natürlich auch seinen eigenen Code so weit unterschreiben, weil der Code ja auch in dem Sinne ein bisschen urheberrechtsverbindlich immer so schön ist, dass man einfach sagen kann, okay, der ist digital unterschrieben und das hat alles seine Richtigkeit.
Da würde mir jetzt so als Anwendung einfallen, Firefox Plugins, die haben ja diese Installationsroutine von Firefox Plugins, bietet ja auch die Möglichkeit, den Code zu signieren. Krass, dass dort?
Sollte funktionieren, ich selber bin kein Programmierer, insofern müsste ich an der Stelle passen, wie das jetzt also technisch alles stattfindet, aber es sollte ganz normal funktionieren.
Nur so als Beispiel, wo ich jetzt konkret gesehen habe, wo Signing in dem Sinne verwendet wird, also in dem Moment, wo man auch das...
Da kriegt man das ja auch angezeigt, immer ist unterschrieben oder ist nicht unterschrieben, also da sollte das funktionieren.
Genau, da wird es auch wirklich interessant, auch jetzt für, sagen wir mal, unabhängige Software-Entwickler, die halt sicherstellen wollen, dass ihre Kunden nicht halt irgendwas machen, dann kann man das eben auch gleich so in die Software- Update-Mechanismen mit einbauen. Prima, super, dann bedanke ich mich, Henrik, bei dir, für das Interview. Und das war Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe 27, am Mikrofon, wie gewohnt, war Tim Pritlove. Und wir sehen uns bald beim nächsten Podcast. Das war jetzt, wie gesagt, der letzte vom Linux-Tag. Und demnächst geht es weiter mit irgendeinem anderen interessanten Thema.